Warning, this episode may contain
content that is not suitable for
children. Viewer discretion is advised.
Hey everyone, welcome to LED Live, the
show where we talk about pop culture in
light of the Bible. Today, we're going
to ask the question, does consuming
violent media make you more violent?
Find out on this episode of LED Live.
Light exposing darkness.
Well, welcome everyone to our show.
Before we jump into our topic, we want
to mention a couple of things. We are on
Patreon and we really appreciate our
Patreon supporters. You can go on there
and check out all the different levels.
There are many um
uh prizes, if you will, for people who
sign up at different levels. You know,
$1 you get early access, $5 you get
behind the scenes, $15 you get an
exclusive t-shirt that is a producer
t-shirt. We don't print it for anybody
else and you can look at the rest of the
rewards on Patreon. So, make sure you
check that out.
We also want to let you know that we are
more than just YouTube. We have a
website. You can check us out on
littlelightstudios.tv and we have
several products there. We've produced
many full-length documentaries on, for
example, superheroes and cartoons and
video games and just the effects of
media on your mind. One of those in
particular is called Pseudology. It is a
full-length documentary on how you are
affected by media from a very scientific
perspective. So, we encourage you to
check that out and we also have digital
downloads on Vimeo. So, you want to take
a look at those if you prefer the
digital downloads. They're really great
for people who are overseas and don't
want to wait on a DVD to get to their
door. Now, another thing that we do is
we go out and speak. Now, Scotty, you're
wearing a t-shirt there. What is that
all about?
the Philippines. I just got this t-shirt
actually at the Scarborough Church up in
Toronto, Canada. And uh had a great
weekend speaking up there. So, if you
don't know, uh we actually go to
different churches throughout the year.
Keith, how many churches have we been to
this year? Oh, about two dozen. Two
dozen? We've been to probably four or
five different countries. So, if you
want us to come to your church and talk
on media issues, social media, any of
those, um we have a lot of of
information that we can share with your
church. Uh you can go to our website
littlelightstudios.tv
and check out the booking request.
That's right. I was just in Connecticut.
So, hello to everybody in Connecticut.
And we also want to talk to you about
supertonic. Take it away, Scotty.
Tommy's tonics. Today's show is actually
sponsored by this awesome product. My
brother makes it. It's called Tommy's
tonic. It's a supertonic. It's juiced
garlic, ginger, habanero, white onion,
and horseradish. Let me tell you, if you
have a cold and you need to get rid of
this cold, this stuff will burn those
bugs out of your out of your breath.
It's actually really not that bad, but
really it's one of those products that
actually totally works. And as we're
coming into the flu season and a lot of
people are are getting sick, we have
this available on our website. It's
awesome. Tommy's tonic. Check it out.
Yeah. Another thing that's really
helpful is to just don't eat sugar. All
right. So, today we are going to talk
about media violence. As you know, there
is violence in the media. There's all
kinds of violence in the media. And so,
just to get started though, I want to do
a little bit of an icebreaker with you
guys. I know we've been starting to do
these little fun things in the beginning
of our show. I have no idea how this is
going to go. So,
there may be bugs. If they are, we're
just going to cut to the point where
everything works out, okay? So,
um so, here's the icebreaker. We're
going to do a poll and here's the QR
code, but I can also send you guys a
link on Slack. And the poll is going to
be I'm going to have you guys look at
different movie posters and I want you
to tell me whether you think it's rated
R or PG-13. Just off of the poster. Just
off of the poster.
Okay. Okay. I like this. All right. So,
yeah, you're you're going to need a
phone, Maggie.
Okay. Let's go get it. Die Hard, 1988.
Rated R. I'd say rated R. PG-13.
Live Free or Die Hard, 2007.
I think all the Die Hards are going to
be rated R. Really? I bet you I bet you
it's going to be PG-13. Just knowing
that that like violence is just getting
worse and worse. So, I'm I'm going to
guess PG-13.
Because it's 2007? That's right.
It is PG-13. Really?
Disturbia. Every killer lives next door
to someone.
Rated R. Yeah, there's just so many
rated R movies. I just say rated R. It's
PG-13. Taken.
2008.
Yeah, I'd say 13.
Yeah, 13. PG-13. Watching a lot of
movies. The Dark Knight. The Dark
Knight's two PG-13.
Rated R. Yeah, it is PG-13.
I think every Terminator movie was rated
R, I think. Now, Terminator, I don't
know. So, is this the
Which one which number was this?
The first one might have been rated R.
This is not the last one. This is
somewhere in the middle. The end begins.
I'm going to guess PG-13 again because
the violence is getting worse. Dude,
look at his face. I don't get it. It's
You're you're rating it lower.
Because we're more exposed to violence,
so they're going, "Oh, this isn't bad.
This isn't that bad." But they have a
standard like if it has X, Y, and Z,
it's rated R.
good stuff. That That That That would be
an old standard. No, okay. Have you seen
the movie? Cuz there's things like, you
know,
if the blood is blue, it doesn't matter
like how the person dies, just that it
wasn't real blood, it's PG-13.
Even if the head explodes and it's blue
blood. So, this one
is PG-13. Told you. Told you.
The first one was rated R and it was
cheesy. I'm on a roll. Sucker Punch.
PG-13.
I'm going to say rated R.
It was PG-13. Interesting. But there was
a lot of people who actually said this
movie should have been rated R.
Yeah, cuz I remember seeing the trailer
for this. I did not see the movie, but
it was pretty violent. PG-13. Man of
Steel.
That's PG-13. Yeah, you guys got that
one right.
The Lone Ranger. I'm going to say PG-13.
Yeah, PG-13. Rated R.
Tracers.
PG-13.
Yeah, I would say PG-13 judging on that.
Yeah, looks like it. Maybe. That's all I
know about it. Originally rated R. Hm.
But they changed this one, too. Cuz they
had
blue blood.
Yeah. Brogan. Well, let's let's let's
get to this uh discussion, right? And
the question is, is there a link between
media and violence? What do you think?
You know, looking at some of the studies
that that I I've seen that came out
about countries that didn't have any
kind of media whatsoever. And all of a
sudden, like we're talking like African
countries or something and they
introduced I I think it was like Sesame
Street or something, like something
benign like that. And they all of a
sudden started having problems in
society. I heard about that. Um so, I'm
going to bet that
there's got to be some kind of effect. I
know that in the United States, we have
a lot of exposure to violence and
I don't know. I don't I It's so hard to
say. I don't know definitively. When you
did the video game one, we talked about
how like
uh we thought violent there was more
violence here than there was in China or
Japan or something, but then we looked
it up and they're like super censoring
over there. Yeah. Like they don't even
let you show skeletons and things like
that. So, Yeah. I think there's a link
between media and our tolerance towards
violence, you know, what we pass as,
"Okay." and what we what we actually get
uh offended by or react to. And I would
almost say if things progress like it
got really bad, like Holocaust bad, you
know what I mean? Like I think we would
react to that really fast because we're
probably all just super desensitized.
But then you see people whipping out
their phones when there's a fight going
on or somebody like A kid's drowning and
they're like videoing it.
Laughing. Yeah, I mean they we we we I
think have lost our connection with
Yeah.
human life. We're not as sensitive as we
used to be.
Well, let's get into this thing. In
2018, Parents Television Council, they
published a report about media and
violence. And what they looked at was
the years 2013 to 2017 when they were
doing this report. And here's um
some of what they were looking at. They
said,
"In 2000, the American Academy of
Pediatrics," this is one group,
"American Academy of Child and
Adolescent Psychiatry, the American
Psychological Association, the American
Medical Association, the American
Academy of Family Physicians." Okay, we
got uh so, a list going here. "and the
American Psychiatric Association." All
these groups, they they issued a joint
statement. Okay?
And um
this statement declared that reports
from the Surgeon General's office and
from the National Institute of Mental
Health and numerous studies conducted by
leading figures, okay? We're really
building here.
"said our medical and public health
organizations point overwhelmingly
to a causal connection between media
violence and aggressive behavior in some
children." Yeah. Now, there's a They're
not saying every child and they're not
saying that it necessarily affects them
the same way, but they are saying there
is a link here. And this is based on 30
years of research.
I I mean, I would just say like all the
problems that we have with bullying and
even the kids not caring about the
well-being of the other kids,
you know, you look at like what happened
in the '50s or '40s or '30s. The kids
weren't like probably straight mean like
they are today. I mean, they're passing
around notes in high school. Like that
documentary we watched uh trying to sign
a petition for kids to commit suicide. I
mean, that's just terrible. Yeah. So, I
think that's Well, there's the the
phrase copycat for a reason. And And
just look at a bunch of kids that like
come out of the movie theater after
watching some, you know, action-packed
movie. They're all like, "Wow, yeah."
Right. And you you got a movie like
Joker, and now all of a sudden they're
putting armed guards at the theater
because they're worried about people
reacting to it. So, you know. But
there's no connection. Yeah. So, this
report, they wanted to take a heavy look
at specifically gun violence, okay? And
media.
So, here's one of the things they
concluded. They said PG-13 movies exceed
the amount of gun violence in the top
grossing rated R movies. Hm.
That's I thought that was weird.
kind of surprising because you would
think, you know, rated R, more violent.
But as I was going through this
information,
what I was discovering is that usually
films that are rated R are rated R more
for
sexuality Yeah, and then they're rated R
for violence.
Interesting. So, it's not that films
aren't rated R for violence. Usually
they are, but but if you look at a bunch
of films that are rated R, look at one
that's just rated R for violence that
doesn't have any sexuality in it. That's
probably not a very long list, right?
You've usually got a mix of everything.
Mhm.
So,
they they concluded, and this is from
Annenberg Public Policy Center. It's
from the University of Pennsylvania. So,
PG-13 movies exceeded the amount of gun
violence. And I bet you that there's
more PG-13 movies because it it opens
them so selves up to a wider audience.
You know, this is an interesting point.
We're actually going to get to that. So,
hold on to that thought. So, what they
did is they took a look at, you know,
2013 and they compared it to 2017
because around this time the government
was like, in 2013, they're like, "Man,
this gun violence thing is starting to
get real. Like, we need to we need to do
something about this, right?" And so,
the government was calling for better
regulation and and what do we what do we
do? So, they said, "Okay,
the government's calling for better
regulation 2013, so
what happens over the next 4 years? Does
anything change?" Hm. Right? So, they
wanted to see, does anything change?
Here's what they found out. They said,
"In 2017, the total number of violent
incidents in 1 month of television and
the percentage of programs containing
violence and the percentage of programs
containing violence and guns
and the percentage of violent programs
with ratings didn't adequately reflect
the program's level of violence." So,
they all increased. Hm.
All increased, okay? Hm. I would bet
that, you know, I'll let you finish
first before I comment. There were fewer
episodes of entertainment programming
aired during the study period in 2017
than 2013.
Which means even that the concentration
of violence was greater. So, yeah, I
kind of there was like a loss of
translation. So, to summarize, are you
saying they they showed less violence
for a while, but violence rose anyway?
No. So, to summarize, they're saying
um
in 2017, all the markers for violence
went up. Mhm. So,
even though the government's calling for
greater regulation, over 4 years, it
didn't go down. If anything, it went up
and the concentration was greater in
2017. In film production. In Yeah, in
television. I think this is particularly
in television programming. Wow. Okay,
we're not even talking about movies yet.
This is in television programming.
Now, if I had to guess why, it seems
like um just human psychology, it's like
if we get addicted to something, you
just need more and more and more. So, I
think we've gotten used to a certain
level of stimulus, and then all of a
sudden it's like we need the scenes
crazier and bigger. I mean,
I was watching this thing on the um
what's a Bollywood guys? And like the
crazy stunt scenes that they do in
Bollywood, but they're just so out there
ridiculous. But they they need that kind
of stimulation because they've probably
seen everything before. Yeah, it's just
constantly how can we go bigger and
better and whatever. They got to outdo
the next guy. Wow. One of the things
that they concluded was that the rating
system, okay? It's what has allowed
violent content in the PG-13 films.
Right? So, they're saying it's it's the
ratings, people. It's their fault,
right? They're the ones that allowed
this. Now, I want to look at
statistically something that you touched
on just a little bit ago and you were
saying, you know, there's probably more
PG-13 movies
in all actuality,
there are
fewer PG-13 movies compared to rated R
movies
Interesting. that have ever been made.
Interesting. So, the So, the bulk of
movies that have been made, 58% have
been rated R. Hm. And this is since
they've had a rating system in place.
Hm. Because parents are less caring.
They're like, "Ah, it's a rated R movie.
I'll take my kids." Maybe it makes it
more exciting. Which means when you say
that the that there are more acts of
violence in the PG-13
film category,
it's super concentrated then
compared to rated R films. Hm.
Right? This is very surprising. Wow. It
is very surprising. One of the ways that
me that we measure um
violence is with uh
kill count, okay, in movies. So, I want
to show you some numbers here, okay? I
thought this was really interesting.
Here's some numbers from yesteryear. Um
1941. We'll look at my decade, okay?
Sergeant York had a kill count of 83 in
one movie. In one movie. Yeah. This is
in the '40s.
Yeah, right. It's kind of like a
wholesome movie though, right? I
Honestly, I have not seen it. Okay. So,
I I remember movies uh like Do you ever
remember a movie called Hot Shots? Yes.
It was kind of making fun of like a lot
of like It was part deux, remember?
Yeah, and they would have the kill
count.
Yeah, they would have the kill count.
There was actually a graph that was
going.
But it's comedy deaths. Oh my goodness.
In the '50s, it was Godzilla with 111,
okay? Now, watch how it jumps into the
'60s, just a few years later, The Alamo,
525.
Wow.
In one film. The Alamo.
The next decade, the greatest kill count
was from the movie Duck, You Sucker.
Okay? 1971. Had a kill count of less
than The Alamo. It was at 509. Hm. Hm.
And we get to the '80s, 1989, there's a
movie called Glory. Mhm. Seems like I
might have seen that, but I don't
remember.
Denzel Washington. Okay. Yeah, I
probably did. So, it was about the Civil
War. Yeah. Super bloody and violent. Oh,
well, then that makes sense. 584 Right.
Was the kill count. But but if you just
consider those numbers, I mean, think
about it. A movie is only 90 minutes
long. So, if you kill 500 people, what
are you killing them every 10 seconds,
you know? It's like Now, these are these
are acts of violence that you would that
you could witness on screen. Like, it
plays out before you. We're not talking
about, you know, they said they killed
so many people and you didn't see it
happen, yeah, okay?
So,
okay, just keep that in mind.
or a mass? Like, if you toss a bomb into
a building and there was like a thousand
people
if you toss a bomb into a building and
you watch it,
then it's supposed to count. And I'm
pretty sure. You see the person die.
Yeah, if you've seen it die.
By the time we get to the '90s, it's a
Braveheart and the number jumps quite a
bit. It's at 1,297.
Wow. Okay, so it's more than double. I
remember kids in in high school watching
that movie 50 times. Oh, yeah. I mean,
it I've probably seen it, you know, 20,
30 times, you know? And it was super
violent.
Yeah. Yeah.
We get to 2000. Okay? The Sum of All
Fears.
2,922.
Wow. Now Now we jumped
again. I've never even heard of that
movie. Quite a bit.
Title sounds familiar. Yeah. Is it some
horror film?
Man. No, no, no, no. I It seems like The
Sum of All Fears. I could be wrong on
this. So, don't don't hate me, viewers,
if I get this wrong. But I thought it
was a in like that Tom Clancy series.
Okay.
Um like one of those um
What was that character?
Um like Jack Ryan series. I think.
I think that was a Ben Affleck film.
Whoa, you missed a major point. Go back.
I missed a major point?
Yeah.
What's my major point? You have
Braveheart rated R, 1,200. But then The
Sum of All Fears is PG-13.
It is. And And I'm kind of leading
leading up to that a little bit, yeah.
It is PG-13 and has more than twice the
kill count
in the film. Okay.
So, now I want to show you greatest of
all time list, top 10. Okay.
Of all all decades since there's been
ratings, okay? Well, maybe even before
there's been ratings cuz Sergeant York
was in 1941. They didn't start ratings
until
So, here we go. Top 10 kill counts.
2012, The Avengers, how many do you
think?
The Avengers? Half the planet, right?
Yeah, right. Right, right, right. Yeah,
millions. I don't know. Okay, there's
the number, 1,019. Wow.
Interesting. Doesn't seem quite so bad
as some of the others that we've seen on
our list. Hm. Number nine, Braveheart.
Okay, so it's on the top 10 list.
Number eight, The Hobbit: The Battle of
Five Armies in 2014, there was 1,417
killed. Number seven, Matrix Revolutions
in 2013.
Yeah, I thought that would have been on
there. There was 1,647
killed in that film. Lord of the Rings:
The Two The Two Towers in 2002. I didn't
expect Lord of the Rings to make the
list. There was those battle scenes, I
think, that you saw. I mean, I maybe
they're counting orcs and that kind of
stuff. I don't know. Yeah, there was a
big battle scenes in there. So, 1,700.
Number five, 300: Rise of an Empire in
2014, there were 2,234.
Now, number four, The Lord of the Rings:
The Return of the King in 2003. This is
a This is a series I didn't I just I
didn't realize The Lord of the Rings was
so violent like that. But it was so long
ago that saw them. But, look at the jump
so far from the bottom on this top 10
list to where at number four. It's It's
you know, like almost tripled. The Sum
of All Fears actually came in at number
three of all time. So, that was the 2000
and 1922. Number two, Dracula Untold.
Now, look at the jump. 5,687.
Wow. Wow.
Okay. Big big jump in numbers.
2014. 2014, okay. The biggest of all
time. Now, now this one This might
surprise you. Okay? Both the number and
the film.
Um and there's a reason that there's
another movie that didn't beat it out.
We'll We'll discuss that. So.
Guardians of the Galaxy, 2014, 83,871.
Wow. Is that many actors? Yeah, because
you just saw that many people like Yeah,
there was some scene where you had mass
destruction.
This is This is what was counted out.
Now, in my mind I'm going like, wait a
minute. What about Star Wars? Like,
shouldn't Star Wars be on this list? And
for some reason that I guess the
discrepancy was whether the kill count
was on screen or not. Otherwise, like if
you were just counting, you know, based
on whether you seen it or not, Star Wars
was upwards of over 300,000. Wow. And
those are estimates because
they don't really know how many people
are on the Death Star, so
how do you count that? Not really sure.
Right. So, but Guardians of the Galaxy,
a huge jump. And that film was rated
Can you guess? PG-13. It was PG-13.
Cuz they want the kids to go watch it.
They do.
So, partly explaining some of the data
that we looked at, right? But, you can't
watch a video about abortion. Yeah.
Wow. Think about that. Educational. So,
this is from gocompare.com. If you want
to check out the data, you can go to
that website and look for yourself how
they counted it and and all of that.
All right. Now, I want to read this
quote from this same report that we were
discussing from Parents Television
Council. It said, "Hollywood stands at
the very nader of hypocrisy." Why is
that? So many voices in Hollywood, from
actors to writers to producers, they
loudly condemn gun violence.
Yeah. But, they are unwilling to condemn
their own industry for promoting a
culture of violence. I mean, they you
know, when I was in Canada over this
last weekend, I'm telling you
we I did a question and answer after the
presentation. Mhm. People would raise
their hand and be like, why do you
Americans have so many guns?
Like Wow. What does that really have to
do with it? Yeah, the topic that we just
saw, but actually, you know what? It
does.
When you promote and you see that all
the time, I mean, it's like fashion,
right? How does fashion catch on? People
see it all the time and then all of a
sudden they take on. Mhm.
But, I thought that was very
interesting.
Really stepping on their toes there.
Yeah. Because you can decry it all day
long, but if you're not going to do
anything about it and you're just going
to line your pocket with the proceeds
from the films that are doing that,
Mhm.
you don't have much to say.
That is There's a lot of double
standards going on there, I bet. Yeah.
For sure. Like, who are they crying to?
The government to make changes? And when
once the government starts impeding on
their industries, then it's a problem.
Yeah. Parents Television Council does
cry for the government to make changes.
They actually lobby the government on
stuff like this to to see standards
raised and and those kind of things. So,
I know I know they have They are a
lobbyist group. I mean, you think about
like the movie Heat. You guys remember
way back when when there was a bank
robbery in Los Angeles and those guys
literally recreated the Heat scene.
I mean, down to like, you know, like
they thought they were literally living
out the movie.
were wearing and everything. Yeah, when
they when they went to their homes, they
found multiple copies of that film at
their homes. That was a big thing of
their of their of their movies. So, why
isn't Hollywood jumping on going like,
listen guys, we should not be making
movies like this. We want to stop
violence. You know, some violent act
happens, a school shooting or something,
and it's like they just point the finger
at like, you know, take away the guns.
But, you know, what about the
inspiration behind a lot of that?
Exactly. There's a There's an interview
I remember watching when Suicide Squad
came out, you know, the actors were
saying, you know, like these aren't the
best role models and I would not want
this role model for my kid. It's like,
then why are you making something like
that, you know?
money talks.
Yeah.
So, the MPAA,
how is programming rated, right? Well,
here's a here's a little statement.
This is This is the idealistic part of
the quote I'm going to share with you,
okay?
Raters adhere to general guidelines to
determine a movie's rating.
Okay, we know that. They adhere to
guidelines, right? And that's how they
determine how all this
works out. Well, here's the rest of the
quote.
While raters adhere to guidelines to
determine a movie's rating, as parents'
opinions on sex, profanity, and violence
evolve throughout the years,
the board's ratings have adjusted to
reflect those changing views.
That's exactly what I was thinking about
earlier. It's like, how come there isn't
just a certain template? Like, if
there's over 100 deaths, it's stamped
rated R. But, that is changing. We've
seen Yeah, there's a couple of things
out there that
um
it was interesting to me like if you
drop uh
if you drop the F-word more than once,
it's an automatic rated R.
But, has that changed?
And it can be in your PG-13 film.
But, if you if you drop it twice,
automatic R rated. Oh, no. I can't
believe they said it twice. Yeah, a
little poison. Wow.
Yeah.
So, I don't I don't remember some of the
others, but I know I remember reading
that one. So, now we're starting to see
some of the issues with the rating
system, right? The ratings evolve
because society evolves.
But, we're evolving because of what
we're being desensitized to.
loop, right?
And Well, I've seen 100 deaths before.
No big deal. So, we see our current
values getting reflected in the rating
system.
And this
it leads to something that we call
ratings creep. You ever heard that term?
Ratings creep?
Yeah, that's that's what they call it.
And there's scientific evidence to
actually support that phenomenon. So,
here's a um from the journal Pediatrics,
this came out in 2014. Here's what they
said. "Parents become desensitized in to
both violence and sex in movies, which
may contribute to the increasing
appearance of both types of content by
both parents and the raters employed by
the film industry." By the time our kids
are grown, it's just going to be like
anything is rated PG, you know. Right.
The more parents watch, the more likely
they are to not have a problem with it.
And
or for their kids? That's the thing.
Well, with recommending it. Because
they're as they're watching, their
standards are just like lowering, right?
Cuz they're getting used to it. Right. I
mean, if you think about some of those
superhero movies that made it onto this
list, they're pretty violent. But, but
you you see the little kids that have
all seen these movies. I mean, these
some of these movies are just terrible.
And so, yeah, I mean, that starts with
the parents, I'm sure, starting to watch
it. Then they don't feel, you know, eh,
they're desensitized by They're They're
numbed by it. Numbed might be a really
good word. They're numbed by it. Then
their kids are like, eh, you can watch
it, too, you know. But, they don't They
don't have that sensitivity. Mhm. Yeah,
I went to my in-laws' house one time and
their their son, he was probably like 10
at the time, and just on the TV was
playing the movie Sin City.
And and we were all just conversating
and stuff, but the boy, he was just all
into it. And I look up and I see the
dude like hacking someone's head off and
holding it up and I I was just kind of
like, uh, and his dad was like,
"Yeah, you probably shouldn't be
watching that." But, he didn't turn it
off. And it's just like
this is what our kids are growing up on,
man. cannibalism in that movie. There
was I mean, there was terrible things.
Just absolutely The The name. Yeah.
Yeah.
That's a clue.
All right. So, I want to show you
a
uh
clip from Dr. Dimitri Christakis. And he
works with Seattle Children's Research
Institute. He's an MD, PhD. He's like an
expert in child development, okay?
And so, cuz we know parents are
desensitized,
Hollywood's not really doing anything to
curb it. Um
so, is there anything else at play?
Listen to what he has to say. Number
five.
The news and information sources need to
stop presenting the findings linking uh
screen violence, virtual violence, with
real-world aggression as if they're
controversial. There is a overwhelming
scientific consensus that that link is
real and should be taken seriously. So,
now he's blaming somebody else that
throwing in into the mix, right? The
news media
is presenting conflicting information to
the public
so that they have a hard time making up
their mind or or trying to figure out
what reality is, you know? And so, it's
it's like that with
with a ton of things, right? And you
look back years ago, right?
One of the ways that the tobacco
industry was was working was through uh
news and media, right? And they're like,
okay, you know, cigarettes are great for
you, you know, we'll put all this
information out there. And then they
hire
um people to do scientific studies,
right? And those studies are skewed, and
so out in the media and they're like
they're confused because, well, you
know, cigarettes are fine for you
because, you know, more doctors use
Camels than any other brand. And then
the public's going like, oh, you know, I
guess there's nothing wrong with
cigarettes, you know?
And then somebody comes out with a a
real scientific study, you know, that's
that's not skewed, and it says, "No,
cigarettes are bad for you." And then
they're like
wait a minute, what am I what am I
supposed to think, you know? You talk to
just about anybody today and they're
going through the same thing. They're
like, well, I don't know if there's, you
know, a link between violence and media
cuz they hear both things going on
through the news media. Probably because
it's more common to get your information
from the news source then people aren't
sitting there floating through this
unless you have, yeah, unless you have
an interest in this topic, you're
probably not just scoping out the
internet for all the fine print in
whatever study. And so, you know, this
video, I've never even seen it and I've
I've looked for kind of things like this
in this topic. So, you know, it's a
whole lot easier to just throw the news
on every single morning or Good Morning
America and you know, they'll mention
something and, you know, they're But,
but it shows you how the truth is
getting buried. Yeah. Yeah, you know,
because he's saying there is an
overwhelming
scientific consensus. It's not just
like, yeah, we think they're kind of is.
He's like, no, this is this is real.
Right. Stop saying that it's not.
So, have you ever heard this before? I'm
not going to kill anybody because of
playing a violent game. Oh, yeah.
Absolutely, yeah.
I've heard that, too. And and honestly,
I'm going to, you know, if we're being
realistic, I believe those people. I
think, you know, the majority of people
out there are not going to go out and
kill somebody because they played a
violent game or a violent video game or
something like that. But, I really like
the direction that Dr. Brad Bushman
takes. He's with BYU. And um, I want to
show you just some highlights from some
seminars that he's done on uh, violence
and games, okay?
I cannot tell you how many times I've
heard this quote.
I play violent video games and I've
never killed anyone.
THE FBI ACTUALLY KEEPS TRACK OF eight
big crimes.
I'm not talking about all crimes. I'm
talking about really serious crimes.
Four of them are violent: murder,
forcible rape, robbery, aggravated
assault.
Four of them are property crimes. These
are serious things like burning down
churches and stealing people's cars.
What percent do you think are murders?
Any guesses?
15%?
2%? 1/10 of 1%. Not of all crimes, of
the big eight. If I wanted to find
4.7 murders, I would have to study
100,000 people in America for an entire
year.
You never murdered anyone?
Big deal. It's rare. 1/10 of 1% of
people murder.
What I want to know, and I think what
most parents are concerned about, they
don't worry about, oh, no, if my kid
plays these violent video games, they're
going to become the next Columbine
killer.
They want to know,
well, how do how do these games affect
how they treat me?
How do they affect how they treat their
siblings, their peers, and others?
How do they affect how they see the
world? How do they affect how they see
women?
There are other effects of violent media
beside whether you're going to kill
somebody.
Wow. What do you think about that? He
nailed it. Yeah, he nailed it and that
that makes me think of the verse that
Jesus said in Matthew where it was
basically like, look, you don't have to
murder your brother, but if you're just
angry with him, you might as well have
murdered him.
So, are we creating
like verbal violence or verbal abuse in
the same way of, yeah, maybe they're not
going to go out and kill somebody, but
but their tr- mistreatment of their
siblings or parents is probably, you
know, tripled or doubled or whatever.
I'm thinking of that news clip on the
Fortnite video where the guy hit the
husband is playing the Fortnite game and
the wife is trying to get in and he's
like, hits her and she's like, I don't
hit me and she's pregnant with his baby
and all this stuff, you know.
So, I thought that was I thought it was
really well said and and really put
things into a really good perspective
because
that's what we are all dealing with in
everyday life is how we're treating each
other. So,
all right. So, I'm going to show you
another clip from this uh, same series.
Um,
and here we go. We can't randomly assign
people to play violent or non-violent
video games and then give them guns and
knives and see what they do with them.
You know, so you have researchers have
to be very creative about how do you
measure aggressive behavior? Here's a
study we did in the Netherlands. The
participants in this study were Dutch
boys. They're about 14 years old and we
randomly assigned them to play a violent
or non-violent video game for 20
minutes. After playing the game, they
rated how cool they thought the players
were in the games, how much they wanted
to be like these characters, and then
they competed to see who could press a
button faster and the winner gets to
blast the loser with loud noise through
headphones.
They didn't have to, though. We didn't
force them to behave aggressively. They
could choose no noise. They could also
decide how long the other boy suffered
by how long they held down the duration
button. So, they could give the other
boy really loud blasts of noise
for as long as they wanted. And
participants in our study were told that
if they selected levels eight, nine, and
10, they could cause permanent hearing
damage to their partner.
They couldn't, actually, but you can
imagine that a boy might think hearing
noise levels louder than what you heard
for uh, extended periods of time
could
maybe have such effects.
So, here's some actual comments from
these boys.
I blasted him with level 10 noise
because he deserved it.
I know he can get hearing damage, but I
don't care.
So, these boys are identifying with
these violent characters and it's
clearly influencing their behavior.
I told you about one study, but there
are 140 studies
showing very similar results.
Wow. 140 studies
showing similar results. That's That's a
lot of studies.
It's like a line that we're towing when
we don't really understand what it means
to kill someone. It's not always
physical. Just causing pain and verbal
abuse, as you were saying, all equates
to some level of destroying that
person's
Yeah, it makes makes me think of the
verse in the Bible where it says, um, in
the end of time, the love of many will
grow cold. Yeah.
How how do you fix something when you're
in an argument in a relationship? I
mean, you know, you're you guys are
married. You'll you'll experience this
someday, I'm sure, Kennedy.
Um, but it's all not peaches and cream.
I just break it to you there, you know,
marriage is actually there are some
disagreements that happen in there. But,
how do you solve that disagreement,
right? If we're constantly um, watching
things that how do you solve a
disagreement?
You know, like do what I say or I'm
going to pull the trigger, then all of a
sudden it's like that just puts you in
the in the mode of like, I'm going to
force you into my way of thinking or or
or the outcome, yeah, the outcome is
going to do this or die.
And that doesn't teach society how to
like, you know, work together and I
mean, I could just see like, you know,
if if if you watch a lot of this stuff,
it's got to have an impact upon your
marriage. Has to. That's exactly
basically the same type of um,
method that Moses learned when he was in
Egypt, learning to be a ruler of Egypt,
right? The methodology was force. Like,
you don't do what we say, we're going to
make you, right? We're going to put
military might behind it. Then God
extracts him out of that and puts him in
an environment of servitude.
And he learns to
lead and by serving the next 40 years.
It's like God is undoing
what he was learning, you know, it's
like God's saying, no, no, no, no, we're
not going to lead by force.
We're going to lead by being a servant.
Right, that's God's way.
One of the testimonies of the boys,
he said, you know, I pressed level 10
because
I don't care. Yeah. You know.
And it reminded me of what you were
talking about how certain industries,
they pay scientists to find, you know,
do those positives and publish that and
it's kind of skewed. Then, you know,
okay, video games won't make you pick up
a gun and kill someone, but it'll make
you do X, Y, and Z. It'll make you more
aggressive, maybe numb you to things
that are going on and and just more, you
know, aggravated about little things.
It's like, you know, when when you're
when they released about wine, you know,
it's good to drink wine because of your
heart. And it's like, no, won't you just
eat the grape, you know, like that.
There's no side effects with that.
Right. So, they use the first part of
the sentence, but they leave out the
part that there's other things that give
you that same result.
Exactly. Yeah. Yeah. Mhm.
I want to show you another clip from the
same series. I I have I think I have
about five in total, but they're real
short, you know, about a minute or so.
So, we did a brainwave study and in this
study, um, participants were either
violent or non-violent game players
and we measured their brain waves uh,
while they saw neutral, negative, and
violent images. The negative images are
really important because they provide a
control
uh, with the violent images.
So, here's the neutral images, things
like mushrooms.
Here's the negative images like a dead
dog and a baby with a birth defect. And
here's the violent images like a man
putting a gun down another man's throat
and a man holding a knife against this
woman's throat. Everybody hates these
images. They don't like them. But, these
images are not in video games.
But, there's a lot of guns and knives in
video games.
So, you can see here's the neutral
images. They're the solid lines like the
mushrooms. Nobody is shocked by by
mushrooms.
But, people see these negative images
like the dead dog and the baby with the
birth defect. And when people see those,
you get a huge curve. And it doesn't
matter whether you're violent or
nonviolent game player, those curves are
virtually the same.
Nonviolent game players, they see
a man sticking a gun down a another
man's throat and a man holding a knife
against a woman's throat. Wow, that's
shocking. But, look at violent game
players. They're not nearly as shocked.
They become numb to violent images.
They're not shocking anymore.
That was genius study right there. I'll
tell you what, though, if my daughter
saw the picture of the mushrooms, she
would have a huge fight.
She hates mushrooms. That's hilarious.
That's a no-go for her.
But, I'll tell you, I actually met a
girl who was from South America and she
was from Venezuela and she was talking
about like the violence that happens in
Venezuela. And so, I asked her like, you
know, have you ever seen a dead body?
She said, "Tons of them." And I was
like, "Really?" Like she's like, "Oh,
yeah, they're in the streets. When you
walk around, you step over them and this
and that." And I was just like, "I've
never seen one." I mean, I would I would
literally like like it would it would
cause a action to me. And she says, "You
just get used to it." And that's what
people that go through violent
situations like that, they they become
accustomed to it. So, the more that
you're exposed to it, I mean, it's human
nature. That's how that's how people got
through war times and terrible things.
They're just they're just used to seeing
that. Wow. I don't think we were ever
meant to be used to seeing that. No.
All right. So, the next thing I want to
show you is his three reasons why we
deny the effects of media. I thought
that was so was really good.
Cognitive dissonance is when when we
have conflicting thoughts, it causes
psychological discomfort and this is
called cognitive dissonance. A person
may say, "Oh, man, I love playing
violent video games. They're really
fun." And then, they they read about
some scientific studies showing that
violent video games can be harmful.
Well, those conflict with each other.
So, what do they do?
These studies are crap. These
researchers are idiots. The methods are
flawed.
The researchers are biased.
Another reason is psychological
reactance. People hate others telling
them what to do.
When that happens, there are three
things that that occur.
Whatever somebody tells you can't have
this, we want it more. We try harder to
get it. And we aggress against the
person who tries to stop us.
Another reason is the third-person
effect.
This is a very robust finding. People
believe that media have a much stronger
influence on other people than on
themselves.
We asked 700 about 700 college students.
Does violent TV harm kids? Yeah, it
harms kids.
Does it harm everybody? Sure. Does it
harm the average college student? You
bet. Does it harm you personally? No
way.
This is the average of 700 college
students and this is the average college
student. Why isn't the average of the
college students equal to the average
college student? It's because of this
third-person effect. It's very robust.
His delivery method was just
Right.
brilliant.
to like keep that video in my pocket.
I know. I was like, "Wow, that was I
mean, it makes a lot of sense, right?"
And I I think
it doesn't have to be just this topic. I
think we all need to realize whatever
topic we're presented with, it's easy to
go through the same steps, you know?
Somebody presents you something that's
that's true, but you don't believe it's
true, you're going to go through that
Like cigarettes cause cancer. Not me.
Yeah.
My grandmother smoked till she was 90.
Yeah, and the funny thing is is like
there's so much evidence there, but the
fact that they could actually still
convince the populace that that
cigarettes don't harm you is
Oh, there's a warning on there. Ah, it's
not for me. Yeah, right. You know, other
people. Yeah. It's it's amazing how we
all can fall into that trap so easily
that it affects everybody but me. When
you're younger,
I say that at the age I am now,
you don't think so much about the things
that you're going to that the things
that you do,
you could die. Yeah.
Right?
That affects everybody else, but you
know, I'm invincible or whatever. You
know, you you'll do crazy stuff and and
you think you're going to live forever,
you know?
And then, you I don't know. It's
probably different ages for different
people. For me, I was in my 30s. I was
like, "Man,
I really am going to die. Like I mean,
that's going to happen.
And I am not invincible, you know? There
and now I'm like now I'm getting to that
stage where I'm like real cautious. Like
I don't want to get up on a ladder.
Right. Right. Like man, people drive
fast on the interstate.
That's right. I'm going to make sure I
last, you know?
So, it's
She's still in that invincible yeah.
But, I just yeah.
We can apply that to multiple parts of
our lives, but I thought it was really
really relevant to this topic and how
people will do that cuz I've gone out
and spoken and heard these same kind of
reactions, you know, it's it's it
affects everybody but me or, you know,
those studies are are not right or
they're not real or what about this
study that I read that supports my
viewpoint, you know, we got to be
careful not to fall into that trap. What
about prosocial stuff? And we've touched
on this, right? Not all games are bad,
right? But,
playing certain games will affect our
behavior. So, they also did a study on
that. Like depending on what kind of
game that you play, how does that affect
your behavior? So, I want to show that
to you now. I would just like to say
media are a tool. Like any tool, you can
use it for good or you can use it for
ill. And we've done also some research
showing that media can be used in a
positive way.
In this study, college students played
an E-rated game. It was a prosocial game
like Super Mario Sunshine or Chibi-Robo
where they like cleaned up pollution and
did good deeds. Or, they played a
neutral game like Pinball and Super
Monkey Ball Deluxe. Or, they played a
violent game like Ty the Tasmanian Tiger
2: Crash Bandicoot: The Wrath of Cortex.
And then, we told them by the flip of
the coin, one of them would choose easy,
medium, or hard tangram puzzles. And if
you don't know what a tangram puzzle is,
it looks like this. It's a shape and you
have to rearrange these shapes to make
an object.
So, these are easy.
These are medium.
These are really hard.
And we told participants, "If your
partner solves all 11 of these in 10
minutes, they get 10 bucks."
So, if you're really nice, what you'll
do is you will assign your partner easy
tangrams so they can get the 10 bucks.
If you're a jerk, what you will do is
assign your partners these kind of
tangrams so there's no way they can get
the money.
And that's exactly what we find.
Here's assigning easy tangrams, helpful,
being helpful. Who assigned the most?
Prosocial video game players. Middle,
neutral. Least, violent game players.
Here's the jerks who assigned really
hard tangrams. Who assigned the most
really hard tangrams? The violent game
players. Neutral, middle.
Lowest, prosocial. So, prosocial has
opposite effects as
violent video games. Studies are genius,
man. Yeah, this guy's doing really good
here. So, so I wonder if this applies to
commenters as well. Those that are
really harsh and mean and whatever. Like
I'm going to ask, are you watching
violent movies or playing violent video
games? I mean, I wonder. You know how
some people approach
even in the comment section something
very simple like, "Hey, man, you know, I
heard what you had to say and you know,
I came across this study and you should
check it out. Look at this." That's one
way to approach. The other one is like,
"Dude, you guys are full of it, man. Why
are you even on the internet?" You know
what I mean? Like that's totally like
two totally different polar opposites.
But, I guarantee you if you sat those
people down that are really harsh in the
comment section, they're they're they're
probably playing all these games and
watching all these crazy movies.
of them will tell you. Yeah. This is my
favorite game. It doesn't affect me.
Yeah, yeah.
And while they're punching out their mom
or whatever. Like that. I'm playing in
the middle of a comment.
Okay. Well, we should be careful not to
make fun of
people that are commenting on our
channel.
Yeah, we're going to get a lot of
comments. You would
you don't want to incite their anger
just like you were talking about.
You know, so we should be we should be
Those comments exist. Go look at them.
But, yeah, we do get those kind of
comments. We we see both sides of the
coin, right? All right.
So now, it's time to drop the bomb.
Okay? So, that stuff was good, right?
The what Dr. Bushman put out was was
really good. But, now we're going to
drop what I call the bomb. Are you ready
for this? Mhm. Okay. Here we go. This
comes from the Journal of Adolescent
Health. Here's what it says. The only
effect slightly larger than the effect
of media violence on aggression is that
of cigarette smoking on lung cancer.
Well, that's all.
Interesting. I mean, that like the
that's that's huge because
Slightly larger.
Cigarette smoking and lung cancer is so
well established.
I mean, you're not arguing with that,
right? I mean, every pack of cigarettes
comes with a Surgeon General's warning.
Hey, this can give you lung cancer,
right? Because it's been so well
established in science. And they're
saying the only thing
that this is the only thing that's
uh
has a larger effect only slightly
than media and violence on aggression.
Wow. So, there's a huge
huge um
evidence
consensus in the scientific community
that here it is, it exists. Just like
Dr. Dimitri Christakis was saying, like
it you know, the news people, they are
not doing this topic justice. They're
not preventing they're not presenting
the right information. They're
presenting they
you know, conflicting information to you
guys all the time, but all the
scientists know this thing is linked and
it's well established. So
I wonder if that's for ratings or what.
They're afraid to like make people
angry, so they
like they want people to keep watching
the news, so we're not going to knock
their violent video games or something.
I don't know. I mean, you wonder how
many people in the media industry are
going through the same things that he
just pointed out, you know, the three
reasons that we deny you know, the
effects of this stuff on us. So, I don't
know.
It could be politics.
Who the masses are going for, who's pay
paying who. And I also think it's like
drugs.
We are addicted to
um the feelings and the more heightened
that those feelings are, then more
tickets sales. And so, you know, it's
like they they have to keep kind of
pushing that button. If we're getting
numb, then they're going bigger, you
know.
I was having lunch recently with a
sociologist when I was out on a speaking
weekend in Texas.
And uh she's she teaches sociology.
She's a professor. And she told me the
exact same thing unsolicited. Like I
didn't I wasn't necessarily talking
about this particular thing and she told
me that same exact thing. I was like,
oh, wow. That's really interesting cuz I
had just come across that quote. I want
to I want to talk about four points to
ponder when it comes to
violence in the Bible because a lot of
people are have noticed like, man, the
Old Testament has a ton of violence.
Like, what what's going on? Like with
all of that. How do we How do we put
that into perspective, you know, and and
a and address that with today's world.
So, here's some things to think about,
okay? For our for our audience and for
our guys to discuss. Number one, the
entire Bible from beginning to end never
deviates from the standard of justice
as well as grace.
Mhm. Okay? Jesus is crystal clear. You
know that uh evildoers will be punished
in the judgment day, you know, when when
when he says it's time, you know, he
says, in fact, in Matthew, he says,
depart from me, you who are cursed into
eternal fire prepared for the devil and
his angels. That comes from Matthew
25:41.
So, Jesus is not shy even about this
subject. He's like, look, there is um
there is going to be destruction and
um
for those who are insistent on holding
on to evil and sin and their evil ways.
This is not, of course, for people who
repent and turn from all that. But you
know, there's not just grace in the
Bible. There is justice as well. It's
been that way from the beginning and it
will be that way until the end and then
you know, once it's done, it'll be done.
And that's that's the end of it, you
know, God is trying to put an end of to
all of that stuff.
And so, when he puts an end to all of it
then we're done and after that, it is
eternal life, eternal bliss, happiness
forevermore, no more pain, no more
suffering, no more death, no more
violence, none of that. And that's the
way it will be. So
that's point number one.
You guys have anything to say about
that?
I guess I should ask.
I I don't have to do all the talking.
Okay. Number two, the Bible is very
clear about the unchanging nature of
God. So, this whole idea of God of the
Old Testament, God of the New Testament,
no. It's God through and through, you
know. God does not change. In fact,
James tells us that um
every good gift
um
Hold on a second. I mean, maybe I should
get this right. James declares that
every good gift comes down from the
Father of lights, with whom there is no
variation or shadow of turning. And we
also know that Hebrews tells us in 13:8
that Jesus Christ is the same. Do you
know what is the same? Yesterday, today,
and forever. And forever, right? So, if
it's true, then that follows that there
has not been nor could there ever be any
shift in God's character throughout
time. Okay? So, it's the same God. I
think even when you see judgment in the
Old Testament, God is always like
waiting as long as he can, you know.
The the entire world was thinking only
evil continually and told Noah to preach
120 years and then with, you know, the
little dialogue between Lot and him,
will you save the city for 50? Yeah,
I'll save the city for 50. Will you save
the city for 20? You know, God's like,
look, I've reached a point where none of
them we're saving except you, so you
better get out of there. It's so true. I
mean, the story of Noah is a perfect
example of an Old Testament God that
bore along with the people. And and you
know, he he invited everybody to come
on, get on the boat. I mean, you're
welcome to come in. I'm He didn't
immediately destroy it. He was like
offering for 120 years Noah preached at
them to change their ways. And it says
in Genesis um 6:11,
the earth was also corrupt before God
and the earth was filled with violence.
Like, it was the violence and things
that that caused God
You guys have been looking at my slides,
haven't you?
We're actually getting to all that. And
when it comes to Jonah, you know, God
changes mind about judgment when those
people repented. So And Jonah was upset.
Isn't that grace?
Destroy him, God.
Yeah.
God God had grace and mercy then. Well,
you're talking about reasons for the
violence, but there was still violence.
There was violence. Yes.
So, if I'm playing a video game and, you
know, I give the character grace and
then wait till the very end and then I
smash him. You know, I gave him grace. I
I didn't want them to run away, but they
didn't, so I just kill them.
Well, what if there what if they are
about to kill your child and you don't
you get closer to my child? All right,
you didn't change your ways, I got to
protect my child. That's the way it is
with God, you know. He's protecting Noah
and his family, protecting Lot.
And that corruption had spread to
literally everybody but eight people.
So, it's like a means to an end. Yeah,
so it's like it's like I I think, you
know, it's like cutting off the virus,
you know, it's going to eventually
destroy everybody, so I think that's
what we're living through, you know. God
is not long-suffer or God is not slack
in his return. He's long-suffering. He's
like, man, I keep seeing my people get
persecuted and martyred and and he's
not, you know, knee-jerk reacting and
just destroying everybody. He's letting
this go out until it says
he has to shorten the days or else no
flesh would be saved. Every time that
the state has come in and said, "Worship
or die." Like, literally God has had to
step in at that moment. Every time.
Mhm.
All right. Good stuff. Number three.
All of the biblical authors agree that
God's love and God's judgment are
actually two sides of the same coin.
True. Okay? So, fire can burn.
Fire can also provide warmth and
comfort.
Right? It all depends on where we stand
in relation to the flame.
Both Testaments reflect this truth,
right? Each in its in its own way. So,
if you it I like to think of it like
this, you know, if if we have allowed
God to come into our life and purify us,
go through that purifying fire, if you
will
we can be in his presence.
Right? If we if we choose to not allow
God to come into our life and and purify
us, then we are consumed.
Right? Cuz the fire will destroy us.
Right? But we have to be
we have to let God purify us.
So.
All right. Point number four. This is
the last point. Jesus and the New
Testament writers never complain about
the violence in the Old Testament. Mhm.
Maybe that's a a yellow caution light in
our in our hasty dismissal of the Old
Testament, right? Are we more morally
sensitive
than Jesus
and the New Testament writers?
Did they see something in the Old
Testament that we missed?
Right? So, these are these are points to
ponder, things to think about.
Yeah, I think it was because it was
the end of the day it was like a a way
of life and just because we don't see
the same acts of violence in the New
Testament as in the Old Testament, I
think it's just because it wasn't
recorded. I mean, there was still a
whole world going on outside of what
Jesus was doing um that just wasn't
recorded, but it is in history.
Yeah, it definitely is in history.
So, when I was thinking about this topic
um I was thinking about it from maybe a
slightly different perspective that you
two are starting to touch on.
Um and that's this.
You get to Genesis and after eight
verses
in chapter four, okay? See, 1 2 3 4,
Genesis 4:8 verses and
um Adam and Eve, they had been decreed
to leave the garden and we read this.
Cain and Cain talked with Abel his
brother. And it came to pass when they
were in the field that Cain rose against
Abel his brother and slew him.
One of the firstfruits of sin
was violence.
That we read about, anyway. I mean,
there's I mean, from the time that they
left the garden and or killed, you know,
until the time that these guys were
older, there's a lot of time there.
But it's not the details aren't
recorded, right? We we don't know, but
we know this detail.
And that was that uh Cain killed his
brother Abel. And God showed mercy and
grace on him.
Put a mark on him that nobody would hurt
him.
He did let him live, you know. Didn't
let anybody else kill him.
So, we see violence very early on after
sin in the Bible. We also see this that
you guys were alluding to. This is in
Genesis 6:11. It says, "The earth was
also corrupt before God, and the earth
was filled with violence." It tells us
of that time that man's thoughts were
only evil continually.
I mean, that's that's bad, right? When
when like all your thoughts are just
evil
continually.
So, I'm thinking
okay.
So, sin enters the world, but before
there was sin
there was no violence.
Right? Yeah.
It was the way that God designed it. He
designed a world without violence.
Without sin, without destruction,
without without any of that. It was
Eden.
And what God wants
is to see Eden restored. Which brings up
a really good point of simply If you can
sit down and you can look at the media
that you're watching or the games that
you're playing, and you can say I can
actually picture myself doing this in
heaven. Yeah. That should give you a
barometer right there. I mean, if you if
you're going to play Fortnite in heaven
and run around and kill everybody and be
the last man man standing
you need to probably read the Bible a
little bit more, but
you know, like like I don't think
anybody in their right Christian mind is
going to say we're not going to enjoy
those kind of evil things in heaven. We
We're not going to enjoy watching people
die or get hurt. And that should tell
you right now we should not be doing
that here. Yeah, it's like our our
carnality. We're we're living according
to the the lust of the flesh, like
That's right. I enjoy it.
says if you don't put to death the deeds
of the flesh, you will die. Yeah, for
sure. When someone asks, you know, how
do you just how do you reconcile, you
know, the violence in the Bible and in
our lives? It seems like they're
trying to use the Bible's violence as a
justification for them to indulge in the
lust of their flesh. Which is which is
kind of scary when just just because
your world is full of violence doesn't
mean you have to partake in it. And
Christ asks us to rise above that, rise
higher, to have his light shine through
you, and hopefully impact the world
around you and not have the world impact
you. Right. God has been very patient
with the human race just because
examples of God's followers have had
multiple wives. That is not okay in our
world setting. You know what I mean? So,
it's like you can't look at the Bible
and be like, "Oh, well Solomon had 700,
so I'm going to go for it." That
wouldn't make any sense. So, you you're
hitting the nail on the head. You have
to like, you know, think of the cultural
time that we live in. What we have to
think about, too, is when sin happened,
something that was set in order that was
never meant to happen, and that was
death. Mhm. God said the wages of sin is
death. That is that is the reward of
sin. So, once sin comes on the scene
now
death comes with it, right? And and so,
you know, we we can sit here and say
"Well, I don't understand you, God.
Like, why did you choose to do this with
these people and these people and these
people? And there are whole nations that
were wiped out, and you told the
Israelites to go in and take care of all
these people, you know?" And God can
really
he can turn that back on us, I think,
very fairly and say, "Hey, look.
Mhm.
You guys are the ones that chose this
path. You chose sin. These are the
natural consequences
of all of this.
It it it it just is. It's like a natural
order of thing. Like, once sin starts,
there's going to be death, there's going
to be destruction, there's going to be
violence, going to be all these terrible
things that are set in motion that I
never
wanted to happen. But it's a natural
consequence and result. And the Bible
tells us in Galatians, it says um
you know, whatever a man sows that's
what he'll reap.
And so, man, humanity as a whole, we
we've sown a lot.
Mhm. And we're reaping a lot.
Bible says in Revelation chapter 20,
verses 7 through 9, it reads this, "And
when the thousand years were expired,
Satan shall be loosed out of his prison,
and shall go out to deceive the nations
which are in the four quarters of the
earth, Gog and Magog, to gather them to
battle.
The number of whom is as the sand of the
sea, and they went up on the breadth of
the earth and compassed the camp of the
saints about in the beloved city. And
fire came down from God out of heaven
and devoured them." I find it very
interesting that just before everything
wraps up shortly before sin comes to an
end, right? What does Satan do? He stirs
up violence, right? He's like
getting all these people ready to go to
battle. And what is the results of
battle and war? People die. There are
people that are injured. There I mean,
people
lose in that situation.
And then
um of course, this is after the
millennium has ended, and he's trying to
get the
his troops rallied and take the heavenly
city
by force.
You know? So, sin and violence have have
they've
been together since the beginning, and
they continue. Mhm. Right? This is the
fruit. It's continued all the way down
to the end. Nothing has changed, right?
Nothing has changed about Satan and sin.
It's it's all saying, "You know what?
The wages of that sin, it's death. It
just keeps bringing death with it
everywhere it goes."
And again, you see
Christ saving his people from being
destroyed by the violence. Mhm.
But I like the way that that
the Bible paints this picture for the
redeemed in the end. It says, "God shall
wipe away all the tears from their eyes.
And there shall be no more death,
neither sorrow, nor crying. Neither
shall be any more pain. For the former
things are passed away."
There's a day coming where none of this
stuff is going to be a problem Mhm.
anymore.
Amen.
And
I want to read um
wrap this up with this verse from Isaiah
I think is is really beautiful. It's
It's really painting a picture of what
it will be like in heaven. It says,
"Violence shall no more be heard in thy
land.
Wasting nor destruction within thy
borders, but thou shalt call thy walls
salvation, and thy gates praise." Wow.
I think if we want to be citizens of
heaven, we should start living like that
now. And to me, that's one of the
strongest evidences for why we should
put away violence from our lives Mhm. is
God never intended in the beginning.
When God restores things at the end,
it's not going to be a part of that
scenario, either. So, why would we want
to participate that in that now, right?
Why do it in this time? We should try to
strive to put away those things away
from our lives and live according to
that Eden restored mentality. Amen. And
do a test, you know, like if you are
caught up in in violent video games or,
you know, you you really love the
violent movies or whatever like that. Go
for a period of time without any of
that. Mhm. And just see what what does
that do to your mood? Mhm. You know what
I mean? If you're really a Christian,
you're really seeking a righteous life
pray this prayer as well. God is this
something that you want me to be engaged
in? Do you want me to watch these
movies? If you don't, I give you
permission to come in and change my
heart. I guarantee you that that you
will hear that still small voice being
like, you know, "Hey, this is this is
not profitable, and and and could have a
massive impact upon your just simple
mood and the way you treat other
people."
Yeah, what do you guys think about this
question? What are you preparing for?
In whatever you do, whatever you eat,
whatever you put on, what are you
preparing for? If you're sitting down
and playing a violent video game, what
is that preparing your mind for? What is
it doing to your mind?
Good point. versus doing something else.
Good point. battles
point.
All right. Well, that has been another
episode of LED Live. Is there a link
between violence and media? I think
after watching these things and going
through this information, we can
conclusively say, "Yes, there is." Does
that mean that we believe or think that,
you know, by playing a violent video
game or watching a violent movie, you're
going to go straight out and start
killing people?" No, we're not saying
that at all.
But we are saying that the science is
clear that it is linked to aggression,
and that we can see this in our everyday
lives. You know, it can make us
more aggressive at home towards our
spouse or our kids or our co-workers or
what have what have you. There is a link
there, and we need to be um careful how
much violence we consume. And I don't
think it should be a part of our lives
because we are trying to go to heaven,
right? And if we're going to heaven we
didn't have violence in the beginning
when there was no sin, we won't have
violence in the end when there is no
sin. So, we want to as Kindy said,
prepare. What are we preparing for? Now,
we want to prepare for heaven, so that
is our admonition to you is let's
live like we're citizens of heaven
today. So, thank you for watching, and
we hope you have enjoyed this segment of
LED Live, and we will catch you on the
next episode. Take care, and thanks for
watching.